hey everyone dear volo here and in
today's video we are finally going to be
going over the conclusion of komitsu no
yaiba and the future that tanjiro along
with everyone from the demonstrator core
fought for for over 1 000 long and
brutal years so just before we jump into
today's video if you are new around here
then do make sure you hit that subscribe
button and also be sure to leave a like
on the video as well i honestly really
need it after the absolute storm that
hit my channel over the past few days if
you guys haven't noticed and it would
help me out more than you could possibly
imagine with pushing my content back
into youtube's algorithm but anyway
enough of that let's get straight into
the finale of this beautiful and serene
series that is demon slayer as time
flies forward from the small heart that
tanjiro nezuko zenitsu
we see a large modern city three
generations in the future kanata kamado
who resembles kano in appearance is the
great great grandson of tanjido and kano
and the eldest son of the kamado family
as he tries to wake his younger brother
sumihiko up who almost looks exactly
like a young gatanjido he tells him that
he will be late for school however
sumihiko sleepily responds that he is
already up but kanata sees that he is
barely awake and leaves for school on
his own leaving sumehiko to deal with
waking up himself over at the future
agatsuma household yoshitero reads the
legend of zenitsu a supposed
autobiography of his great-grandfather
zenitsu agatsuma and cries when he
reaches the part where they defeated
muzan kibatsuji suddenly his sister toko
who resembles their great grandmother
nezuko kicks yoshitaru in the back and
tells him to stop reading their
great-grandfather's novel of lies and to
focus on his study as his grades had
been unruly low he objects to being sent
to go study but toko twists his ear and
tells him that the demon's lair studied
too which she uses in a way to trick him
into following suit with the two also
only being great-grandchildren this
proves the fact that both zenitsu and
nezuko lived long lives together
azinitsu himself never achieved the
demon slayer mark and thus would have
not died before the age of 25. as the
two of them make their way to school
together yoshiteru thinks to himself how
the other woman and his family were all
quiet and polite batoco was nothing like
them with an annoyed expression he asked
toko if she believed in reincarnation
and she merely snapped at him asking
what he was making such an expression
for yoshitiro then said while something
like that was hard to prove conclusively
it was his belief that everyone who had
died while fighting the demons for a
peaceful world had found some kind of
path to happiness toku ignores him and
looks at the news alert on her phone
with admiration which declares that an
athlete called tenma uzui had won a gold
medal in gymnastics for japan at only 20
years of age taking his ancestor tink
and uzui's appearance into style and
physique yoshitiru says that tenma was a
rude and nasty person but tauko defends
him and says that it was truly possible
to get away with anything if one was as
good looking and of course as flashy as
he is another news story catches
yoshiteru's eye and he snatches toko's
phone from her much to her irritation he
opens the story about a beautiful
looking botanist called ayoba hashibera
who had discovered a real flower called
the blue spider lily ayoba is the
great-grandson of inosuke hashibera and
aoe kanzaki who also would have lived
long fulfilling lives together just like
zenitsu and nizuko it also reveals the
true reasoning behind why museum would
have never been able to achieve his goal
of finding the blue spot early as it was
an extremely rare plant that only
bloomed during the day on occasion every
few years and for two or three days
every year making it near impossible for
muzan to achieve his actual goal
obviously though we never know and this
could have possibly changed if he had
formed some kind of relationship with a
human who could have searched for it
during the day which thankfully never
happened though sadly though in the
future ayoba had come under intense
criticism following a mistake in their
handling of the lilies which caused them
all to wither and he was forced to
apologize at a press conference
yoshitiro denounces this attitude
towards such a stunning and beautiful
woman but toku corrects him and tells
him that aroba is in fact a man much to
his shock and disgust as the two
continued onward they encountered a
woman pushing two strollers with twin
children in them they were wrapped in
nice mispatton blankets and had black
hair reminiscent of the toquito twins
muchiro and yuchiro yushitiro taking on
the personality of zanitsu asked if they
were girls or not and toko said he was
creepy to which he cried out and
declared that he was not creepy at all
the two then passed a pair of female
students and yoshitiru immediately
recognizes that they are from the nearby
sakira women's academy with the two
students having an exact likeness to
that of kane kocho and shinobu toku
looks at her brother with extreme
disappointment but is quickly distracted
when she spots kanata she eagerly runs
over to tell him he looked cute with
kanata returning the compliment to her
delight joshuiteru mutters that he had
been learning how to cast curses and
says that they should watch out but toku
angrily tells him to repeat himself and
what she quickly apologizes as his voice
begins to tremble they then cross next
to the kindergarten and yoshiteru stares
at the teacher who happens to look
exactly like gyome but also notes that
he looked funny in his pink apron toko
asks kanata if he wants to go with her
to a certain diner on their way home
kanata asks if she meant the one with
the snake decor and the giant serving
sizes to which toko confirms and canada
responds that he is unsure if he could
ever show his face there again he shares
the story of when he was last at their
store with yoshiteru the boy had been
completely transfixed with the woman's
chest who had worked there obviously
this woman just happened to resemble the
voluptuous matsuri her husband who also
worked in the store got mad and had
thrown a knife at him and of course he
looked like no one other than obanai
also finally fulfilling the wish that
the two had made on their deathbeds toko
turns around to yoshiteru in disgust and
rage as the boy stammers claiming that
this was a false accusation and that he
was not looking at her chest back at the
kamado household sumihiko finally wakes
up and notices that he was running late
wondering why no one had come and woken
him up he then gets ready for school and
dives out of his window to the bottom of
their apartment and sprints for his
school on his way he passes a house with
two elderly men playing shogi they bear
a resemblance and wear robes similar to
that of sekonji njigoros they yell out
at sumahiko asking him why he did this
every morning meanwhile on the old men's
television a news report began about an
ubiyashiki who had set the record for
the eldest living japanese person this
ubishiki is actually karaya meaning that
over a century after muzan's defeat
karia is still alive and the oldest
living person in japan being at least
108 years old the fact that he lives so
long is amazing proof that the illness
which previously cursed their family is
now long gone with muzan when kara first
learns about the curse being broken he
didn't believe it but as he grew past
the age of 20 and then 30 it cemented to
him that the curse was truly gone this
made him cry for hours alongside his
wife children and sisters tsumihiko
continues racing and while running he
runs past a store called haganesuka
maintenance and three girls who
recognize him as the running man these
girls all closely resemble sumi kio and
naho asumahiko arrives at a traffic
light that had just gone green he
attempts to jump over the hood of a
police car to avoid having to stop which
startles the policemen inside who both
look like the brothers tsunemi and genya
the policeman resembling genya is
actually his descendant and is incensed
and believes that sumihiko must be the
one they have had seven reports of they
attempt to chase after him but sumahiko
dashes off even faster he crosses a
group of three children bearing a
resemblance to our boy tomioka and his
best friends sabito and makomo the boy
resembling tomioka is named geechee and
is a confirmed descendant of giyus
probably a great great grandson just
like sumahiko is of tanjudo the boys
have some rare toys which are shaped
like the masks once made by sakonji for
his pupils the girl says she has spent
all her allowance luckily though they
give her one of theirs so that she can
have one as well at the school yoshi's
hero watches as a boy named goto looks
at his phone it's an image of a
beautiful woman who looks just like
tamiyo yoshiteru interrupts a boy and
his friend says that he recognizes that
as one of the paintings of yushiro
yamamoto which is obviously the only
remaining demon alive yushiro who has
followed through with tanjuro's last
wishes to him and kept the memory of
tamiya alive through the paintings of
her in the future yoshiro had begun to
receive acclaim throughout the world for
his paintings of tamiyo which was said
to be like photographs yoshitiro notes
that yushiro would attempt to shoot at
any reporters who came to ask him
questions but mentions that his first
love was number 812 tamio with dark blue
flowers he then walks off leaving the
two boys bewildered at him and his
personality sumihiko continues to run
and is joined by tojiro one of the
descendants from rengoku's bloodline
tojiro even resembles kyogiro
specifically with his fiery hair
greeting the boy sumahiko says that it's
unusual for him to be late and tojiro
explains that he woke up at 4 am but got
absorbed into his training throughout
the morning he says that he couldn't
hear anything until his father whacked
him suddenly the police car from before
draws nearer to the boys pestering
sumihiko for him to stop tojiro tells
sumihiko that he should get into a sport
but he responds that it will just cut
into his sleeping time toduro is adamant
though that he would be great at
whatever sport he picked they keep
running even as police keep up their
chase with them in their car the police
are screaming at them to stop as they
arrive at their high school we're a
teacher who looks just like the demon
slayer corps member murata asks for the
gate to be closed as soon as he sees
sumahiko the person at the gate says
that there are still three minutes
before it should close but the teacher
insists that sumihiko is a habitual
offender as the gate begins to shut
sumihiko says that he believes they will
make it in time and togiro agrees both
of them glide over the gate and land
inside of the school running for their
classes the police car comes to a
screeching halt and the officer looking
like sanemi walks over to the gate and
tells the teacher that they need to talk
ayoba sits on a bench in the park and
notes how it is a quiet day saying he
wishes he could live a quiet life alone
in the mountains back at the kamado
residence sumahiko's mother receives a
phone call and is told of her son's
doing being highly surprised and
apologizing for the trouble her son had
caused next to her on the wall we see a
katana that is actually tangido's black
mature and blade with kyogiro's flame
helped still attached just above the
blade hang some photographs and an old
yellowing picture of all of those who
would survive the battle against muzan
smiling happily together and the two
hanafuda earrings of yeruichitsugiguni
hanging right next to them as this
series finally comes to its end
well this evening was just too good and
honestly i'd love to see uh their
evidence of a future in any kind of
series that i finished so the fact that
we get to see every single descendant of
pretty much every character of
importance throughout this story is
something that is honestly really
awesome and i wish a lot of other mangas
or mangaka followed in a similar path
thing we got to see like the descendants
or that that future bloodline of certain
characters and stuff like that as it's
just a heartfelt thing that i think a
lot of people like to see obviously
that's just in a personal opinion as
well and as someone who's always loved
world building i just love to obviously
get that evidence of a future and
actually meet the characters and the
fact that we do get their names is just
even more fantastic like honestly i'm
going to continue gushing over the
series here for a second but the fact
like i find it awesome how ayoba kept
the feminine look of inosuke or hell
like the descendant of zenitsu uh was
still creepy and weird just like zenitsu
was when he was younger as well and like
this chapter here was just one of those
chapters where you constantly have a
smile on your face the entire time as
you read throughout it and you get all
the little hints from throughout the
story that have been added into this
chapter here into these descendants of
each character and honestly i would have
loved to know if tanjudo or anyone else
who would unlock the demonstra mark
managed to live past the age of 25.
obviously i'm assuming that they didn't
because we know that there's a
difference between the great great
grandparents and the great grandparents
so there's probably some kind of obvious
age difference between the agatsuma and
the kamata families there i've
absolutely loved making these demons
their videos over the past like two or
three months now so i am working to get
all of them back uh hopefully over the
next two or three months but it's just
going to take time sadly if you guys
want more info on that um
then feel free to check out my latest
video which i will leave a link to down
below in the description and or join my
discord and follow my twitter where i
honestly just probably will keep you a
little bit more up to date than updating
you guys on my youtube as i find i'm
just going to continue with what i was
doing and not worry about it too much
and just keep this showing and over time
those videos will come back and also as
well those videos are going to all be up
on patreon i'm uploading them onto a
different platform so that they're
available up on there um i already have
the majority of them up live it's just i
have to get the other few ones up before
i can release them there for you guys
but anyway if you guys aren't your own
here i want to keep up to date with like
the latest anime story explained videos
and just other anime videos in general
then make sure you hit that subscribe
button and also make sure you leave a
like on the video as it'll really help
with pushing my stuff back into
youtube's algorithm after what has just
happened but anyway enough of that for
now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and i will see you
all in april bye